leo do you have any tips about um
getting a mullet and how to maintain a
mullet because
you're ready to go deep i think a good
person to
um to look at is riff raff you know
and riff raff is a he's almost like a
human animal out of florida and if you
look at that man he is very
he really has perfected it you know do
you think he should work his way into
riff raff should he start some with
something like a milder mullet
is there such a thing there's nothing
mild about a mullet
right you're committing bro the crazy
part is the second you freaking grow
that thing you'd look good in one
actually man
yeah definitely but what about me bruh
you are gonna have one soon she said
yes you know what dude and i think it
could be cool i think you you're
definitely gonna love it i think you
should have it i think you know what you
are lucky
that you can um be like that movie
um last in the mohicans [ __ ]
yeah oh but he didn't have a mullet bro
daniel
yeah my right foot i'm gonna do movie
call my right foot
right but i can't do no i can't draw
nothing with it yeah and your foot's
always asleep that's it
yeah and then it gets like gangrene and
i have to lose it whatever you know i
mean we'll write the script
i could see you having a beautiful
mullet though and i think thank you
yeah i really could man and i think it's
time man i think it really would inspire
you to feel
like a different person and make these
guys do them dude make these whites in
here [ __ ] grow them [ __ ] i might
have everyone and even the [ __ ] gooks
in here too right
yeah some of the i don't know i don't
know who is a [ __ ] but yeah
[Music]
very good i feel like you've said that
word before bruh
i mean i've said it i just don't know
who it's at
that's the problem dude that's not a
problem that's really the benefit you
know but i'll tell you why the mama bro
because um
you know my people i don't know if you
know my people but you know i don't know
who's
the phoebe yeah steve yeah and also a
billion other [ __ ] people
yeah yeah that's a lot of people i've
seen a lot of people sleeping in the
airport
but before bieber before bieber some
fool
in china or whatever said
this mushroom bull haircut everybody got
everybody gonna wear these right and it
was some sort of government law or some
[ __ ] so not everyone's got a bowl on
their hand
click click click click right they all
look like [ __ ] ghetto [ __ ] beetles
and whatever
right where at in china in asia wherever
bro
you're never it's only when the k-pop
star started going crazy with the
[ __ ] rooster hairs he tried to change
it you know you should testify this in
the impeachment hearings this makes
notes
but it would fit right in bro on c-span
what do you have you think about it
dude yeah i think either go mullet or
just commit to
um your roots yeah do you look like yoko
no no bro
you gotta do something dude
i never
spoof dude it's just you in the woods
bruh
looking for something but do i get to
meet that white chick
that yeah you get that man elizabeth shu
i think it is yeah i mean
it was remember eliza how big she was it
wasn't elizabeth's shoe man
i don't know beautiful but she is
beautiful oh she's beautiful man when i
think about her dude i think about her a
long time
you do i love her let me ask you
something about women though um i don't
want to get specific you know i mean
because uh
you know we're private here but um uh
you you have you
made love to all varieties or what